- Après une première vague
dévastatrice qui a fait
des milliers de morts,
particulièrement dans
les CHSLD, la situation
s'est redressée au Québec.
Très élevée au départ,
la surmortalité
s'est mise à baisser.
FRÉDÉRIC FLEURY-PAYEUR, Institut
de la statistique du Québec
- La surmortalité, c'est
la différence entre le nombre de
décès qu'on a réellement o
et celui auquel on aurait pu
s'attendre en temps normal.
- De mars 2020 à mars 2022,
le taux de surmortalité
s'est établi à 4,5 %, ce qui
représente 6400 personnes
décédées de plus que prévu.
Pendant la même période,
14 200 décès attribués
à la COVID-19 ont été
rapportés au Québec.
Comment expliquer
cette différence?
On calcule que des personnes
mortes de la COVID auraient
rendu leur dernier souffle
d'une façon ou d'une autre.
- Au cours de la première vague,
une grande partie des personnesr
la COVID étaient dans
des milieux de fin de vie,
donc c'était des gens pour
on pouvait s'attendre
à un décès imminent.
- Selon l'étude de l'Institut
de la statisque du Québec,
la provice se compareareareare
avantageusement avec son taux
de mortalité de 4,5 %,
alors qu'il est de
6,2 % ailleurs au pays,
d'environ 7 % en France,
11 % au Royaume-Uni
et 18 % aux États-Unis.
- Tous les indicateurs
sont à la baisse.
à tous les efforts qu'on
a faits sur la vaccination, on
voit quevoit quevoit quevoit que
décès que dans le reste du
Canada.
Dr LUC BOILEAU, directeur nat.
de santé publique du Québec int.
- C'est fait, comment
on a organisé les services,
les politiques publiques
qui ont été mises de l'avant
pour protéger la population,
les plus vulnérables.
- Mais il ne faut l ne faut l nr
que les mesures sanitaires,
comme les confinements
et les couvre-feux,
ont aussi eu un impact sur
d'autres facteurs de mortalité.
IGNAMI, professeure,
démographie, Université de Mtl
- Les mesures de lock-down ont
contribué à réduire les décès
pour d'autres causes, résultés
par les accidents, par exemple,é
causés par la grippe.
- Résultat : l'espérance
de vie, qui avait baissé
de près de 8 mois en 2020,
repart à la hausse; elle est